I've had many people who were inspiring
models two of them stand out the one was
my graduate advisor Arthur Kornberg who
you know was had the very highest
standards of science and scholarship of
anyone that I've ever met a really
rigorous very demanding tough tough guy
but I've learned a great deal from him
about how to do science and then at a
very different level another great
scientist Daniel koshland was the
chairman of the biochemistry department
at Berkeley when I was hired as a
beginning faculty member and he he had
in addition to great scientific
qualities a concern for science as a
leader of son of scientists so he was
the chairman of the department he was
very collegial he was concerned about
promoting the University and promoting
public higher education and I've taken
his example in doing many other things
that I do so I value him as highly as I
value what I learned from kornberg he
was the editor of the proceedings of the
national academy of science then he
became the editor of science magazine
and I followed in his footsteps I was 45
years the editor-in-chief of the
Proceedings of national academy but then
more recently I've taken on a new role
as editor of a new online journal called
elife which is a journal sponsored by
the Hardys Medical Institute the
Wellcome Trust and Max Planck Society
and we feel very strongly that there's a
need for another journal at the very
high end where the decisions are made by
active scientists and where the
limitations imposed by the print model
are do not apply so we accept papers and
publish full-length papers and we don't
have artificial restrictions based on
some fat or fashion so this is a journal
that all I'm promoting and actually hit
from here in Stockholm i'll be speaking
to journalists about this